that brings up the question
of uh asking for a friend here if
there's
uh you know other pockets of complexity
uh commonly called as uh alien
intelligent
civilizations out there well we don't
know for sure but i
i have a strong suspicion that the
answer is yes because
the uh the one
case we do have at hand to study
here on earth uh we sort of know what
the conditions were that were helpful to
life the right kind of temperature the
right kind of star
that that keeps maintains that
temperature a long time the liquid
environment of water
uh and
once those conditions emerged on earth
which was roughly four and a half
billion years ago it wasn't very long
before
what we call life started to leave
relics
so we can find the uh
forms of life primitive forms of life
that are almost
as old as the earth itself in the sense
that once the earth
became reason was was returned from a
uh a very hot boiling thing and cooled
off into a solid mass with
it with water uh life emerged very very
quickly so
so it seems that these general
conditions for life
uh are enough to to make it happen
uh relatively quickly now
the other lesson i would i think
that one can uh draw from this one
example it's dangerous to
the drug lessons from one example but
that's all we've got
uh and uh that that the emergence of
intelligent life
is a different issue altogether it uh
that took a long time and
seems to have been pretty contingent
uh the you know the the for a long time
well for most most of the history of
life
it was single-celled things
you know uh yes even multi-cellular life
only rose about 600 million years ago so
much
after you know so and the the uh
uh and then
intelligence is kind of a luxury you
know if you think
uh many more kinds of creatures have
uh big stomachs and then big brains and
in fact uh most most most have no brains
at all in
any reasonable sense that that then uh
and the dinosaurs ruled for a long long
time and some of them were pretty smart
but
they they were at best bird brains
because you know birds
came from the dinosaurs uh and
uh and it could have stayed that way you
know and and
then human and the emergence of humans
was very contingent and kind of a
very very recent development on
evolutionary time scales
and uh you can argue about the level of
human intelligence but it's you know i
think it's that's what we're talking
about and it's very
it's very impressive and can ask these
kinds of questions and discuss them
intelligently
uh the uh so
i guess my my so this is a long-winded
answer or justification of
my feeling is that uh the
conditions for life
in some form are probably
satisfied many many places around the
universe
even and even within our galaxy uh
i'm not so sure about the emergence of
intelligent life
or the emergence of technological uh
civilizations that that that seems
uh much more much more contingent and
special and
we might it's conceivable to me that
we're the only example
in the galaxy or although
yeah i don't know one way or the other i
i have different opinions on different
days of the week well one of the things
that worries me
in in uh in the spirit of being humble
that our particular kind of intelligence
is not very special so there's all kinds
of different intelligences
and even more broadly there could be
many different
kinds of life yes so the basic
definition and i just had
i think somebody that you know sarah
walker i just had a very long
conversation with her
about even just the very basic question
of trying to define
what is life from a physics perspective
even that question within itself i think
one of the most fundamental questions
in science and physics and everything is
just
trying to get us hold trying to get some
universal laws around the
ideas of what is life because that kind
of unlocks a bunch of things around
life intelligence consciousness all
those kinds of things i
agree with you in a sense but i think
that's a dangerous question because
the the answer can't be any more precise
than the question
and the the the question what is life
kind of assumes that we have a
definition of life and that it's a
natural phenomena that that can be
distinguished
but that really there are edge cases
like viruses and
uh some people would like to say that
electrons have consciousness and they
you know
so you can't if you really have fuzzy
concepts
it's uh it's very hard to to reach
precise kinds of scientific answers
but i think there's a very fruitful
question that's
adjacent to it which is has been pursued
in different forms
for uh quite a while and is now becoming
very sophisticated
in reaching in new directions and that
is
what are the states of matter that are
possible you know so
in high school or grade school you
learn about solid solids liquids and
gases but that really just scratches the
surface
of different ways that are
distinguishable that matter can
form into uh uh
macroscopically different meaningful
patterns that we call phases and
then there are precise definitions of
what we mean by phases of matter
then uh and that have been worked out
fruitful over
over the decades and we're discovering
new states of matter all the time
and kind of having to work at what we
mean by
matter we're discovering the
capabilities of matter
to organize in interesting ways
and uh the
some of them like liquid crystals
are uh important ingredients of life our
cell membranes are liquid crystals
and that's very important to the way
they work uh
recently there's been a development in
where we're talking about
uh states of matter that not only
not that are not static but that have
dynamics that have that
have characteristic patterns not only in
space but in time
these are called time crystals and
that's that's been a development that's
just in the last decade or so it's
really
really flourishing uh and
so uh is there a state of matter that
cause or a group of states of matter
that corresponds to life
uh maybe but the answer can't be any
more definite than the question
i mean i got to push back on the the the
quite those are just words i mean
i i i disagree with you the the the
question points
to a direction the answer might be able
to be
to be more precise than the question
because
because uh just as you're saying there
there's uh
that we could be discovering certain
characteristics and
patterns that are associated with a
certain type of matter
uh macroscopically speaking and that
that
we can then uh be able to post facto
say this is let's just sign the word
life
kind of matter i agree with that
completely that that's what that's
uh but that's so it's not a disagreement
it's very frequent in physics that
where in science that uh words that are
in common use
gets get refined and reprocessed
into scientific terms that's happened
for things like force and
energy uh and
so we in a way we we find out what the
useful definition
is uh or symmetry for instance
and the common usage may be quite
different from the scientific usage but
the scientific usage
is special and takes on a life of its
own and we find out what the
the useful version of it is
uh or the the fruitful version
of it is so i do think so in that spirit
i think if we uh can
identify states of matter
that or linked states of matter
that can carry on processes of
self-reproduction and development
and information processing
we should say we might be tempted to
classify those
as things as life
you